you know my my kid went and saw this
movie when she was at her mother's so I
thought I'd dodged a bullet but that's
the point we've reached now I just
willingly jumped in front of the bullet
gotta go fast
[Applause]
[Music]
sign the Hedgehog so I made the decision
in doing this review at all to drink my
way through it now I didn't know if it
was necessarily gonna require me to
drink my way through it the way I knew
cats was gonna require me to drink my
way through it um yes I am recording
this immediately after watching it so no
haven't sobered up yet just to be
absolutely clear about that the thing is
I don't think this movie is bad I think
it's bland and about 20 years out of
date
but for what it is it's fine
there's nothing all that wrong with it
but you know I did drink my way through
it and it's not for me and this is gonna
be me mostly rambling about largely
weird things and nitpicky stuff I mean
if you weren't here to tune in for that
base off the thumbnail on Oh Alon alone
then I don't know what to tell you I'm
already losing track of my thoughts I
have the live tweets that I sent out on
my phone as a reference for in place of
notes I have tweets so let me be clear
about a couple things first off I have
zero investment in Sonic
Nintendo kid growing up never had a
Genesis not gonna say never play the
Genesis I did on occasion but liked it
that's I have known nostalgia for the
Genesis I played like a couple of the 2d
Sonics a little I was never good at them
I never played them enough to get a
handle on them and get used to them I
absolutely had no interest in 3d Sonic
I've never I never watched the cartoons
any of them in ever read the comics I
don't know the lore I'm not I'm not part
of this fandom so I want people to
understand that I am a neophyte bitching
about a property I have no investment in
and none of this is intended to make fun
of the people who do have investment if
you care about the lore of Sonic good on
you I don't know it I was gonna say I
don't care about it I can't even make it
opinion of whether or not I care about
it because I don't know anything about
it so if you're telling me I that I
might complain so irrelevant cuz I'm not
a fan fine I guess but okay so it's not
a fresh observation to point out how 90s
this movie is it is the 90s movie to be
made outside of the 90s between Jim
Carrey who I'm pretty sure his only
Direction was hey pretend it's 1994
again to the format of let's take a
character who really should be set in a
completely fantasy world they just drop
them in the middle of Earth so that we
only have to pay for one effect and then
everything else is just locations and
and all that sort of stuff
it's super nineties it's super 90s in
that still trying to recapture ET but
also be a pop culture reference II way
that only nineties children aimed things
could be which is the other thing some
of the stuff I've got a [ __ ] about is
easily hand waved away on the basis of
is aimed at a young audience who won't
notice her won't care I understand that
I'm still gonna [ __ ]
Sonic's an annoying whiny little mmm I'm
the only reason I'm not gonna swear as I
don't want to have to edit it later he's
annoying
and I don't think the loneliness was a
bad angle to go with I think that made a
lot of sense all things considered cuz
if you're gonna make it a thing we're
like he's not on his home planet which
first of all just even that like weird
flashback at the beginning like that
it's just me or is that weirdly
elaborate for blue hedgehog and sneakers
like this that that's weirdly elaborate
and we and also doesn't pay off like it
opens up with him and his adoptive foul
mother protecting him from people who
are hunting him down but the thing is we
never find out why those other whatever
they wars were hunting him down so the
setup never pays off it's just it's just
the excuse to get him into a world that
isn't his own but it's never explained
who those people were why they wanted
Sonic why it was a bad idea for them to
get their hands on Sonic nothing none of
that pays off but if you're not gonna
pay it off why do you have this
elaborate backstory lore why you don't
need that anyways I forgot what original
point I started when I started that I
was gonna say sentence wasn't one
sentence felt like a run-on sentence
whatever it was I forgot one point I was
gonna make but so the the whole thing if
yo I remember if you're gonna have him
be not of this world
and he's here and it's not his home of
birth having him be lonely actually
makes a fair amount of sense and it's a
decent way to explain why he latches on
to somebody like Tom oh and props to
James Marcin he does a surprisingly good
job keeping a straight face not
taking it too serious but II need just
the right amount of serious there's a
line in this that hmm there's a line
that he says I forget what the original
setup is Masonic goes you won't regret
it James Martha's thing goes pretty sure
I will and my immediate thought was that
was the conversation he had with his
agents
what do you agreed to do this movie but
lonely is is solid at that's a good
enough angle to go with but like they
needed to nail down the rest of this
because the thing is is that sonic has
been on earth for a while they don't
give an amount of time I don't think if
they if they do I missed it but it's
weird because he's been here long enough
to know what things are called to have
established kind of a home base I mean
like he knows what baseball is and you
know what donuts are and things like
that but he doesn't know what a phone
booth is which really doesn't make sense
cuz like his favorite movie ever is
speed and one of the first things that
happens in that in the front end of that
movies Kenna Reeves talks to Dennis
Hopper on a pay phone why doesn't he
know what a pay phone is ah mind that
that specific thing actually hadn't
occurred to me until I just said it just
now and that's part of why I got so
upset about it
unwarranted but I did anyways he they
need to decide how much does he know
about this world about how it works
because they they try to have it both
ways they try to have it where the
basics of the world don't have to be
explained doing that they don't have to
explain cars and televisions and and
stuff like that but at the same time he
just doesn't get simple basic stuff it's
weird it's it's an odd mix and I don't
like their it so it's they tried to have
it not bogged down the narrative while
still having weird awkward humor moments
which you know weird awkward humor
yay my favorite kind of
humor and like it's the reason we get
things like Jim Carrey who has been
empowered by freaking US military to the
point that he could tell a commander
local military commander played by Neal
McDonough who looked very confused as to
why he was even in this movie so
confused apparently that he left and
never showed up and stole that
observation from someone who replied to
a tweet so that person stole your joke
sorry you're cool though um but so he's
empowered by the by the US military and
yet he tries to bluff his way into a
house by pretending to be from the Power
Company there's no need for him to do
that except it lends itself to weird
awkward humor and we gotta have that oh
[Applause]
and what's that bar that was not a biker
bar or a cowboy bar pick one because you
went back and forth and I'm actually
like I'm pretty sure I saw a biker punch
a cowboy where is this bar what is this
bar I don't understand like at all so oh
okay so I mentioned Jim Carrey and this
doctor robotnik and again yes I get it
is for kids but it's a classic case of a
character who is smart for two reasons
he has put in scenes with people who are
much much much much much much dumber
than him and who repeatedly claims that
he's super smart but does not actually
demonstrate that in any meaningful ways
the epitome of telling over showing
we're told that he's very smart because
we're told that he designed all these
robots but we don't watch him do it it's
not like Tony start where we get to see
him build anything we don't really see
deductive reasoning at work he basically
has algorithms and drones do all the
work for him so you know we're just
being
old Betty smart and I could prove to you
that he's not because he's convinced he
has the upper hand to take down Sonic
because he's harnessed the power of
Sonics quill that he found
how many quills has he harnessed the
power of one and he thinks he can beat
Sonic who is covered in the quills the
thing that you are using to think I have
all the power now the guy you are trying
to capture and beat is covered in
hundreds if not thousands of this thing
that you think gives you unlimited power
so well however much power you have
times that by a thousand and that's him
and you'd think you have the upper hand
you idiot speaking of idiocy and now
again I know this was not a problem
originally because okay look the
redesign of Sonic we remember the
original trailer the nightmarish look of
the original trailer they redesigned it
to be more cartoonish all things
considered that was a better call except
for the fact that I'm sure they
completely worked a bunch of visual
effects artists absolutely to death and
crunch times which is not cool these
people need a union anyways everybody
else in only what has a union VFX artist
don't what the so my point is they made
him closer to original Sonic which means
they gave him the Mickey Mouse gloves
you know the white gloves things whereas
in the original iteration meaning the
the basis for the actual script and that
design he just had white fur on his hand
the reason I bring that up is because
the next thing I'm gonna complain about
only applies to the final version of the
film we got cuz it only applies to the
complaint from the fact that he has a
glove where's the original design would
have just been his hand and this
complaint wouldn't have been an issue if
it was just his hand but it's not I'm
complaining about the movie that I saw
which is the movie that was released the
fact that was changed I don't care while
I was a little preamble to get to a
really stupid complaint okay so he beats
this robot fake it kind of cool thing
that this thing this drone that's
original that's initially a car and then
it's like it's a motorcycle then it's
like a unicycle then it's like this
little flying tiny
bugged wrong thing it was kind of cool
how it just kept breaking down to like
okay well this bit still works and now
that's coming at them that was actually
pretty cool
but anyway so it's stuck to Sonics and
it starts beeping and blinking which we
all know ah Bom
well he's like ah he can't get it off
his hand you're wearing a glove
take off the glove you stupid blue rats
and again I know originally it wasn't
love it was just his hand and they
weren't gonna rewrite the script just
because they updated the effects and
changed it but I'm still looking at
somebody with a glove on something stuck
to his glove going ah I can't get it off
take off the glove um oh I didn't really
like the front bit at the beginning
where he where he sees the turtles from
the car and like goes running with the
turtle like hold him out and the music
his queens don't stop me now which is a
super obvious pick for a music track for
this movie but it's also Queen it's like
cool I can work with that
and like Jim Carrey for his 1994 or 5 as
he was he slipped into that pretty well
actually props to the man because lots
of people trying to recapture a vibe and
a thing that they used to do but haven't
done on a long time it can come off
really bad he slipped into it pretty
seamlessly like get the wrinkles the
lights are a little deeper in his face
but no no that's uh that's mid-90s Jim
Carrey he's slipped back into that like
it's a glove that he could then take off
if there was something stuck to it that
was going to explode like honestly as
much as I understand that I shouldn't be
complaining about that I that really did
bug the heck out of me I don't know what
oh I don't know why I was stupid enough
to think that I would get through this
movie without a fart joke but there was
a fart joke for no reason and Olive
Garden
product placement that was weird like
the initial name drop when you're here
you're family like but they were saying
that between each other because like it
was a it almost played like an inside
joke cool but then at the end they get a
gift card for Olive Garden and and the
military general plugs the endless
possible it is very weird it's it's up
that it's up there with the first Thor
or oh it was my favorite my favorite
product placement of all time if you
have not seen the Thomas Crown Affair
the remake one with Pierce Brosnan and
Rene Russo it's pretty good actually I
enjoyed it it's good time but there's a
scene where Rene Russo is talking to Dan
Denis Leary
no I could get it and like she suddenly
has a revelations like ah huh and
there's like what she gets up she leaves
her room there and they're like the heck
they follow her out into the hallway to
a Pepsi vending machine where she
proceeds to get out a Pepsi one pop open
drink labelled a camera multiple gulps
and then turn and actually finish the
thought that she had back in the other
room
they literally something we did for her
to leave the room and go and get a Pepsi
it's the stupidest thing that you will
ever see in an otherwise really fun
movie oh god it's so bad why am I
talking about that oh product placement
Olive Garden yeah that was weird I might
not have much else to say it's look this
thing is not the insanity that that Katz
was I'm done with this
so if the movies fine
I'm a Randy drunk so I'm gonna rant
about it that's what happened and I
would like I went and that was my plan
don't think that the movie drove me to
drink
it didn't I went in with a plan to drink
and while watching this movie as someone
with no nostalgia for Sonic it's just is
fine
it only insulted my intelligence a
handful of times at the end of the day
and for anything aimed at a younger
demographic honestly I'll take that
sometimes I've had to take my kid to
some painful movies over the years she's
getting old enough to start to become
discerning so fingers crossed on that
for for the future if we ever get to go
outside and go to movies again oh that
got bummed out hey let's wrap it up
thanks for watching this not sober fool
what did you think about Sonic the
Hedgehog whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
other stuff to do you can like subscribe
you can share this video around you can
check out my patreon page there's a link
to that down in the description plus
links to other things as well such as my
various social medias there's a book
that I wrote and things like that so
feel free to do all that or you don't
have to do any of it because at the end
of the day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and I have
been slowly moving myself closer to the
camera during this entire outro for no
reason other than I decided I was going
to at the last minute until next time
this council nice is over up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]